hallo was geht leute kurz moment ich bin
noch von überlegungen ob ich das video
im stehen aufnehmen soll
oder im sitzen weil ich habe so einen
neuen tisch den kann man verstellen zum
beispiel so jetzt kann ich mich mir das
ist noch zu hoch
also ich würde mal behaupten so es
angenehmer oder bisschen noch so perfekt
okay ich hab mich jetzt eben auf diese
position geeinigt ich starte jetzt noch
mal neu weil irgendwie ist das schwierig
das alles so rüberzubringen wie ich
rüber bringen möchte hey was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
ja leute ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
ich befinde mich hier gerade in meiner
neuen hall wohnung beziehungsweise
gerade sitzen wir hier in meinem büro
und es ist halt fast nichts eingerichtet
deswegen gehalt ist so krass ich hoffe
das kommt bei euch nicht so rüber weil
ich habe hier am mikrofon stehen das ist
bisschen dumm das schwierige ist dabei
nicht auf meine stimme zu konzentrieren
weil die gefühl zwei sekunden später
noch mal zurück in meine ohren kommt
also das was ich sagen und sollte auf
jeden fall jetzt endlich mal die
gelegenheit nutzen auch euch allen hier
die meinen hauptkanal abonniert haben zu
erklären oder ein einblick darin zu
geben was sich bei mir so verändert hat
weil es hat sich in der vergangenheit
einiges geändert und ich hätte niemals
unbedingt gedacht dass ich das wirklich
so durchziehen werde ich habe dazu auf
meinem anderen kanal alex v auch schon
mal ein video gemacht wo ich das so ein
bisschen erzählt habe aber ich habe das
bewusst nicht auf meinem hauptkanal
getan weil ich mir an sich auch noch
nicht zu 100 prozent sicher war dass
jetzt wirklich so zu machen
also ich hab ja drei jahre in köln
gewohnt wie viele von euch wissen ich
habe ja vorher können wurde die wohnung
in köln existiert auch noch aber die ist
jetzt bald weg weil kostet ja auch miete
und ich wohne halt nicht mehr
ich habe das in diesem video auf meinem
auf dem alexa kanal glaube ich ganz gut
erklärt hier vielleicht meinen kurzform
sonst verlinke ich euch das video super
gerne auch in der video beschreibung
ich habe halt in köln ihr müsst euch
vorstellen in der wohnung gewohnt ich
habe da gearbeitet ich hatte einen
mitbewohner und auf dauer am anfang war
irgendwie immer alles alles cool so
großstadt du kannst immer raus gehen und
ich hab mich da richtig wohl gefühlt
aber so jetzt das letzte jahr es war für
mich persönlich es war einfach nur noch
stress ich hatte gar keinen bock mehr
morgens aufzustehen geführt ich hatte
gar keine motivation mehr meine meine
ziele zu verfolgen oder meine meine
videos zu machen oder coole videos zu
produzieren weil es einfach immer nur
stressig war ich hatte nicht viel platz
zum arbeiten
ich hatte immer leute die kam und dann
wird sich da in der küche rebitzer
gemacht oder dann ging die tür auf da
war der lauterstraße ich konnte mich
heute nie wirklich konzentrieren und es
wurde ich hatte das gefühl also so
schlimm wie sich das auch anhört aber
ich glaube hätte ich so weiter gemacht
irgendwann hätte ich so einen burnout
gekriegt oder so weil es einfach so
krass war ich war einfach nur noch
unwirklich und ich hatte gar keinen bock
mehr und dann habe ich so auch wenn ich
das wenn ich das eigentlich gar nicht
gar nicht so wollte ich habe dann
einfach gesagt ich kann das nicht mehr
ich will jetzt ich will jetzt wieder zu
meinen eltern ziehen oder zu in meiner
heimatstadt ziehen und das habe ich dann
auch einfach vom einen auf den anderen
tag gemacht ich habe das allen leuten
gesagt mit dem ich das zu tun hatte auch
natürlich marie beim arimond ja auch in
der nähe von köln
und dann bin ich halt geschafft
zurückgezogen weil ich das einfach
musste so und bis jetzt bräuchte das
auch überhaupt nicht ja da ging
natürlich auch eine gewisse zeit alles
drunter und drüber weil
das ist ja auch nicht so leicht wenn man
dann wieder 180 kilometer weg zieht so
da muss man sich ja auch wieder finden
und dann habe ich halt jetzt eineinhalb
monate bei meinen eltern gewohnt
habt ihr vielleicht auch in den videos
gesehen und hab dann nebenbei schon
angefangen mir auch wurde dann zu
schauen weil ich mir schon dachte ja ich
brauche eine wohnung wo ich halt selber
alleine wohne wo ich genug platz haben
wo ich in mein büro einrichten kann
und dann habe ich diese wohnungen
gefunden die wurden gerade
fertiggestellten nicht überall es ist
einfach ich habe ein fenster im
badezimmer ich habe einen balkon wo es
ruhig ist es ist einfach so es macht
mich so glücklich es ist halt auch ein
land deswegen das ist alles günstiger
und so und alles halt sachen nicht in
köln nicht mehr hatte mit denen ich aber
an sich groß geworden bin natürlich
braucht man dass ich unbedingt zum leben
aber ich habe diese kleinigkeit halt
einfach so vermisst und freue mich jetzt
hier alleine zum boden erstmal und meine
sachen halt zu machen und mit viel mehr
motivation auch in den tag zu starten
und ich glaube man kann sich das nur
vorstellen wenn man wirklich mal
entgegen einer großstadt gewohnt hat und
dass alles einfach zu viel wurde oder
weit weg von seinen ganzen freunden war
von seiner familie war und deswegen ist
das halt so kommen aber ich habe das in
diesem ein video halt wie gesagt da noch
mal genau erklärt hier wollte ich euch
auf jeden fall jetzt auch darüber in
kenntnis setzen was ich so geplant hat
und wie es halt so aussieht also ich bin
halt hier jetzt in erfurt in der bohrung
drin
seit vorgestern um genau zu sein es
folgen jetzt einige sachen ich muss
natürlich noch alles einrichten das wird
auch noch mal den akt sofa muss noch ein
esstisch muss noch rein und es fallen ja
dann immer noch so viele sachen an die
man gar nicht denken
ja aber ich freue mich sehr die jetzt
für mich eigentlich zu können dann will
ich natürlich auch wieder coole videos
hier auf dem kanal produzieren die
wirklich spaß machen anzuschauen und
vielleicht waren es auch gemerkt in der
vergangenheit
es war nicht immer so dass ich so
richtig bock drauf hatte
aber das lag halt an sich nicht an mir
es lag an klingt auch vielleicht doof
aber es lag an der wohnung wo ich in
köln gewonnen und das lag vielleicht
auch in köln an dieser großstadt überall
menschen es war immer laut und das hat
halt alles so ein bisschen darunter
gelitten was viele dann natürlich auch
fragen ja wissen dass mit magie wenn ihr
zu weit auseinander wohnen
das ist natürlich nicht optimal sage ich
mal
aber ich weiß dass ich sowieso sehr sehr
oft in köln sein muss marie zum beispiel
ist jetzt gerade auch hier also wie es
jetzt gerade nicht in der wohnung weil
sie draußen irgendwo ist und sonst
könnte die eigentlich auch noch was dazu
sagen aber wir versuchen das natürlich
irgendwie hinzukriegen und da bin ich
auch sehr optimistisch dass wir das
zusammen hinkriegen auch wenn natürlich
fernbeziehung nicht mal so das gelbe vom
ei sage ich mal
aber ich bin ja an keine als ich bin das
selbstständig deswegen ich kann ja immer
da hinfahren wenn ich bock hab ich kann
mir hat mal eine woche frei einplanen so
als wir haben uns nicht getrennt auch
wenn ich das oft in den kommentaren
gelesen habe es war zwar nicht so leicht
immer aber es hat auf jeden fall alles
so funktioniert dann habe ich glaube ich
auch noch im titel geschrieben was jetzt
so die ziele sind für mich für meine
zukunft ich habe mir hier so eine person
wie sagt man so eine tafel hin gemacht
wo ich immer meine to boost drauf
schreiben kann und auch vielleicht so
ein bisschen die ziele die ich halt für
die woche oder auch fürs jahr habt wobei
ich das da nicht drauf schreiben können
und es wird es ein bisschen lang hat und
was mir einfällt ich habe oft in den
kommentaren gelesen dass ich irgendwie
finanzielle bankrott bin oder so das
stimmt auch nicht also ich bin ich
deswegen zurückgezogen klar köln ist
teurer als hier aber
wie gesagt dass er andere gründe ja das
ist auch nochmal ganz wichtig zu sagen
weil das habe ich sehr oft gelesen auf
jeden fall nächste woche steht jetzt
noch an mein auto das sich an drei jahre
hat also den mustern den gebe ich ab
dann ist ja erst mal weg und dann gibt
es ein neues auto da habe ich mich auch
schon für eines entschieden dass ich
dann auch im laufe des augusts abholen
werde was das für 1 wird habt ihr
vielleicht auf ins auge sehen wenn ihr
mir da nicht folgt macht es gerne
ansonsten gibt es da auch video zu da
freue ich mich schon sehr auf dann habe
ich noch einen guten freund von mir auch
aus köln
aber wir haben so einen social media
dingen zusammen gegründet wo ich auch
viel zeit rein investieren möchte was
ich noch so nebenbei mir auf und möchte
was wir uns aufbauen möchten
und dann gibt es natürlich hier zwei bis
dreimal in der woche eine video und
jeden tag auf einem anderen kanal alex
gibt es auch ein video und das war es
eigentlich ihr merkt vielleicht an mir
dass ich wirklich wirklich bin so dass
darüber zu sprechen und das ist mir so
jetzt wieder mega gut geht und deutlich
besser als als im laufe des letzten
jahres und ja man fühlt sich so ein
bisschen befreit und
ich hoffe ihr habt lust dann weiter in
die videos zu schauen so und ja dann
habe ich glaube ich jetzt das meiste
gesagt was ich sagen wollte
na ja dann könnte ich eigentlich sagen
das war's passiert würde mich freuen
wenn wir den kanal abonniert wenn wir
das noch nicht gemacht hat und dann
sehen wir uns am mittwoch glaube ich
wieder oder am donnerstag da gibt es
dann schon das nächste video das war hat
haut rein und ich freue mich über einen
kommentar und ich freue mich natürlich
wenn ihr irgendwelche tipps habt oder
auch eure erfahrungen was so bei euch so
stress und also was so unglücklich sein
angeht mit irgendwelchen sachen
verbunden die eigentlich gar nicht sein
müssen und dass man dann einfach mal
diesen schritt wagen muss auch wenn man
es nicht will weil ich hatte so in
meinem kopf immer drin du bleibst in
köln du musst ihr können beim köln ist
jetzt ein neuer standpunkt aber wenn man
halt so lange unglückliches irgendwann
geht es ja nicht mehr da muss er raus
ja und das habe ich halt jetzt gemacht
wird mich wollen wir eure erfahrung der
haut rein dank fürs zuschauen